[Music]
i'm lauren zima here at the race to
erase ms gala at the Beverly Hilton Kris
Jenner breathed by all of us reporters
she was here with her man Cory gamble
they did not talk to anybody but I got
the scoop from Kathy Griffin and what
the Kardashians are really like
everybody died for that Instagram what
are your tips on babysitting the
Kardashian children okay you have to
have dogs and treats an old drunk lady I
mean it was magic
so I swear there was a little Northwest
was taking like 18 treats at a time and
throwing them in my dog's my dogs are
like untrained pound dogs so they're
just like long and my mom is like sort
of half blind and tipsy and she's like
somebody give me one of those kids it
was so crazy it was so funny my mom was
truly in her grandma glory and so then I
told my mom that they're my kids
so just yeah I was like surprised mom I
I had some kids I didn't tell you about
will you be asked to babysit again oh
yes I think I'm old young minds very
well I never used bad language occur are
the Kardashian children what we would
expect her to do their personality
surprising I will say they've definitely
normal kids fun sane he was like a
runner like he was just running he kept
running everywhere chasing around after
him he's like a shooting star and then
little oarfish for he treats everywhere
it was chaos but it really fun okay
here's the thing
you a list for I loved my life on the
d-list could you ever return to real
you know what I don't know but if I ever
did it again it might be fun to do like
d-list to legend we're like maybe I'm
out on the d-list on the more but I'm
certainly not a list like I'm trying to
become the love of like Jagger or Cher
four straight I never will which is
where the comment